hate crime attack in new york city the
suspect who sucker-punched an asian
woman
should have never been out on the street
with a staggering of 40
prior arrests and four happening in the
last year alone for
similar random assaults the nypd's
commissioner is fed up
and is blaming bail reform
people that are arrested multiple
multiple multiple times
and released um you know mental illness
is woven into this
potentially we have to do better and and
pat
we're arresting somebody for pushing a
woman down the stairs and then we
release them back into the streets
i mean this is craziness so a guy like
this got failed
40 prior arrests he's like a hand
grenade
you don't keep putting a hand grenade
out on the street
isn't he the real victim though you know
it is amazing to me
how the left can condemn every single
aggression but when there's real
aggression good point
fist to face it's crickets or cicadas
um we learned a couple of lessons here
in this in the world of cause and effect
we need prisons i'm a libertarian but we
need prisons you release violent
offenders who reoffend into the streets
they reoffend the politicians if they
want to release him
they should take them into their own
homes
you know put the you know put your money
where your mouth is you don't put them
among
poor people elderly people in chinatown
sure the prisons are less crowded but
the er
in chinatown is now full with people
with black eyes
or or bruises they need to use kendra's
law more where you know what can
force you know you can compel the insane
the deranged into treatment
uh they stopped doing that as much as
they used to that if you just drive up
one block in new york you could see it
everywhere there
these are grown men hitting elderly
women
okay there has to be a class-action suit
against the city
if you got all these victims together
maybe that would make these
politicians understand that you can't do
this because there seems like there's no
retribution like you never hear
any of the politicians talking about
this we're the only people pointing this
out
why is that because there's no
retribution there's no consequences as a
politician
they just figure out nobody sees this
stuff the media doesn't care because
they don't live in these neighborhoods
they don't give a damn well and if you
try to institutionalize someone like
this the aclu comes along shannon and
says oh no no
violating his constitutional rights but
he can violate anybody else's rights
with his fist yeah my late father was a
law enforcement officer
so i hear from people who are out there
and who have been out there on the front
lines all the time they're so
frustrated that if they bother to do the
paperwork and arrest someone that now
we're going to a lot of
prosecutors who don't want to prosecute
there are a lot of places where
there's bail reform or they're doing
away with enhancements and sentencing
that kind of thing
we've been following and you guys have
two i mean several cases of recalls out
in california i think of the
la district attorney out there gascon
now formal recall underway because crime
victims
victims families of people who've been
killed say this is ridiculous now
the guy ran saying he was going to do
this stuff thousands of
inmates there are going to be eligible
to have re-sentencing or maybe get out
altogether
so when you have that going on and
you've got law enforcement officers
seeing even if we bring someone in you
guys are going to let them go
it's a bad stew in a lot of big cities
right now yeah it's a toxic brew it's
you bail reform
bad judges soft prosecutors defund the
police dagan
it adds up to crimes like this uh
liberal parole boards releasing
not only cop killers but child murderers
and now the idiots in
albany well the liberal idiots are
pushing forward with
even more parole reform here's what's
going on
when these uh when leaders politicians
and bureaucrats get asked about these
policies
they change the subject because they
refuse to own them
they are pro-crime they
are they have no backbone to stand up
for law-abiding citizens and victims
that's how bad it is and it in terms of
what is wrong with saying that a violent
mentally ill person who's a danger to
others
and himself who's been arrested dozens
of times needs to be
off the street but somehow that's racist
they close they're closing rikers island
there are thousands of people who've
been put
out on the street who are walking around
and hitting elderly women
in the face that's where we are it is so
it's so bad even in san francisco though
there were two
and they want to blame hate crimes it's
a hate crime but
it's it's not because of trump there
were two elderly women
who were stabbed in broad daylight one
woman had part of the knife still stuck
in or the handle broke off
the man who hurt them was supposed to be
in prison for 25 years to life
but was let out on a mental health
waiver and they released the x-word the
family released the x-ray of this knife
stuck in the woman
hoping the prosecutor would send the man
to jail
yeah jessica why does your party support
old women being assaulted
it's hugely popular at the polls a
serious question
this is a very difficult segment to be
batting clean up on
and i know that we have a limited time
so i'm going to try to get really fast
through this liberals care when
people are beaten up and they care no
matter what color the perpetrator is and
they've been having a conversation led
frankly by
congress people from the aipi community
like congresswoman grace bang
talking about the spike in crime from
white
and black perpetrators we don't need a
conversation we want action though
well you do need a conversation because
that's where reform comes from and i
will say and
if the reform is needed you get rid of
bail reform and you institutionalize the
crazy people so you're a doctor now and
now you're in charge of creating that
policy expert jessica can i add one
thing can i if you def if you defend
somebody who's being beaten up or you do
or i do
because of the color of our skin we're
going to get thrown in jail we will lose
our jobs we will be on every television
network
that's what it is so if if i tackle
somebody in the street it's going to
happen
run away cry as a as a parting shot i
hope that my colleagues here would agree
that there is no way in hell that i
wouldn't care
that old asian people are getting
punched in the street in chinatown and
i think that that is true from top to
bottom on the democratic side no yes
there are disagreements
garcia who's pro pro crime and anti-cop
i agree i believe i believe that's true
but i don't believe the second part
that the democrats uh cared about this
they only cared about it
when they found that white that white
murderer in atlanta
who killed those women at the massage
parlors and then they found out it was
more about a set he was insane in a sex
crime kind of thing it was about sex
then all of these asian hate crimes
started but they couldn't pin it
on a white movement they don't care if
they can't make it about race
jessica they don't do anything about it
and and
they call voter id an existential risk
to our democracy but if you bring up
black on black crime in chicago
all the majority of the victims are
black they will call you racist
or they'll just say ah that's gang crime
that's a problem
all right you got your ten seconds up
next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else